Chronicle am I allowed to say that
someone on the couch you and you've got
one of those birthday's coming up
is it enough you are allowed yeah next
month yeah oh you're saying the number
if I looked at you I'd be yeah I'm going
to be 50 and I'm so excited yeah we
don't apologize anything good plan
yes absolutely I got a lot of good stuff
like a mansion I don't know are you not
involved in it at all you're just
trusting him I'm not even a great safer
to not good with surprises at all oh no
I actually break out in a cold sore if I
have a surprise well that plus birthday
is really bad little yeah I get those I
get cold sores oh gosh I would like so
but I did have a surprise planning once
when I was 30 and it was so shocking to
me because people had come from overseas
and they set it all up and I sort of
walked in and I broke out in console
look immediately of course right on the
spot yeah
it was so so like my whole body cream
understand because actually I've been on
the phone to my mother here's why I said
and I said Oh dad can you go get my mom
and he's like oh no she's in the garden
right and then I walked in to the room
and my mum was there oh yeah and this
was in Montana and I'm like wow yeah and
then I broke out in a cold or course
is awful my god you're revolting I know
phonographs and also the other thing
with this surprise party I mean I'm sure
some people love surprise party but as a
girl you kind of want to be dressed and
ready for it kind of you don't want to
be in your sweatpants and a t-shirt and
everyone else is all dressed up and
you've got a concern so keep supporting
I think I want you got all the right
here coming before Ian was that a
surprise what you did for the 40th
that's not it's so lovely yeah yeah I
lit up a ton of fireworks and well I
didn't do it but I also broke down all
sorts of things those were gone yeah no
he did fireworks from 40th hmm which was
amazing but just the tools yeah we see I
think that's amazing I just there was
two of you and use it for something yeah
I did well she was shooting a film
Australia yeah could both women film and
we're in this very small town in
Australia and I miraculously found some
company nearby that did fireworks and to
just bring everything you have just ever
doing everything and there was a like a
little mountain top illumining yeah and
I had a couch taken up there dropped off
there and we drove up there and we got
out of the car and I said I look there's
a couch of a huge I can couch myself
down a little bit far without it going
on and that was like ah you win you
[Music]